today we're talking about the good
reason halo infinite's co-op was delayed
what xbox gold members can get for free
next month and more
halo development boss joseph statton has
commented on the delay of halo
infinite's campaign co-op saying it was
a difficult decision but ultimately the
right one speaking to ign staten said
that halo and co-op are synonymous so it
was quote very very hard to choose to
delay the feature but it was essential
so the team could prioritize other areas
and get the game out the door this
holiday those other areas of focus
included optimizing halo infinite so it
ran smoothly on all the devices it's
launching on including an original xbox
one model released in 2013 up to a brand
new high-end pc stanton went on to say
quote i think if you look at those two
choices co-op or optimization and you
put yourself in a customer first mindset
it's clear which one you should choose
even though it hurts microsoft had
previously said that campaign co-op is
expected to launch in season 2. due to
the extension of season 1 until may 2022
fans might have to wait a while for
co-op and it's not the only feature
that's been delayed as forge is expected
to launch after season 2 so it might be
released even later developer 343 has
said it will make announcements in
january about season 2 as well as its
plans for campaign co-op and forge so we
should know more relatively soon
so with just one week left in november
at the time of this recording it's time
to talk about what free games xbox
players can look forward to playing next
month starting december 1st xbox gold
members can grab the escapist 2 and orcs
must die with the latter only being
available until december 15th starting
on the 16th members can grab tropico 5
penultimate edition as well as insanely
twisted shadow planet and don't forget
to claim november's games before it's
too late you've got until november 30th
to grab moving out in lego batman 2 and
until december 15th for kingdom 2 crowns
and in other xbox related news the
series x mini fridge is reportedly
louder than most would like our very own
gabe gerwin recently set up his fridge
and found that it is quote easily as
loud or louder than the actual xbox
series x or ps5 when they have this
spinning
the reason for this is because rather
than cool with some sort of refrigerant
like a well refrigerator it makes use of
thermoelectric cooling the idea is that
it doesn't have to use dangerous
chemicals and the cost is almost
certainly lower but it also means that
the fan is basically just pulling warm
air from the main chamber at all times
to lower the temperature so will the
noise keep you from trying to get one
let me know in the comments section and
we'll catch you tomorrow for another
edition of gamespot news
[Music]
you